regardez pas ce qu'on a fait une compil
aussi des match de ping pong et juste
après il y aura ce défi qui va partir à
papeete on le saura dans une minute
regarde ça va vite oui ça va diminuer
les mariages
et oui elle est avec nous ce soir
richard gasquet
sa maman victoire 5-1
aulas alors richard yalou de vie qui est
au téléphone ou de vie qui a voté pour
toi sur twitter tu vas jouer pour lui
pour le voyage à papeete et pauline a
voté pour moi
attention richard sécheresse servir
richa je sers donc attention on va dire
on dit en trois points
super trois points gagnants parfait
c'est parti
je sers deux fois à l'essai a été solide
quand même été solide c'est ce qu'on me
dit souvent que je fais lui c'est solide
attention c'est parti
or à 45 3
ces propos viennent arrêter rôtissent
arrangerait tout le monde attention je
rappelle que richard joue pour faire
gagner un voyage à papeete à ludwig et
moi je joue pour pauline qui s'est
inscrite sur twitter tu tiens yaris bean
et twitter ja ja je vais accélérer
richard quatre balles de match et encore
des gars au téléphone je crois juste
pour vous dire que non jean ping pong on
est tranquille mais il ya quand même des
gars au téléphone
c
g
du genre
mais le survol des cornichons les chars
qui nous fait l'honneur en est là c'est
un des plus grands champions pensée est
ce qu'on vous dire j'ai joué au tennis
avec lui j'ai pas touché la balle à
l'est vraiment donc voilà c'est là
c'était sur mon terrain donc voila quoi
ou tient roland garros à côté suivant on
y va quand tu veux riche en tout cas
merci mon frère on va se refaire une
revanche sur une vraie table vous
inquiétez pas c'est qu'ils téléphonent à
l'eau gaël monfils gall allô médias elle
savoir google et que ça va tu as vu la
tôle que j'ai vu ça et réussir ici là il
pas laissé jouer horrifié
au téléphone on lève aussi galgun galway
faut que tu viennes me défier t'inquiète
pas quand tu veux et bien quand tu étais
petite voiture encore là je suis arrivé
aujourd'hui en europe
c'est quoi tes en europe se trouverait
matin qu'un accord n'est pas bon petit
gars moi le fait de trouver moi à nous
live a trouvé écho nous arrive à trouver
va défier d'accord qu'ils jugent attendu
le souhaitent plateau elle tue pointe le
bout de ton nez ici et on va faire à
l'affrontement en toi contre moi parce
que j'aurai rappelez moi je suis bon je
vais l'avouer j'ai fait un match contre
gaël monfils richard le dit on a fait un
match ça a duré 17 et on a joué pendant
deux heures et demie et il a gagné au
dernier set 14 12 voilà je voulais dire
c'est la seule personne à m'avoir battu
c'est bon ouais les gars quand tu veux
parce que ici je suis sur mon terrain un
jeu comme rocky ici je peux dire je
perds pas comment c'est ça mon gars
richard d'être là